Tonight.
New video
and OUTFRONT of Lisa Marie Presley.
Just days
before the only child of Elvis
Presley died
from an apparent cardiac arrest.
You can see here, here on Tuesday,
walking slowly
being helped down the stairs
of the Golden Globes.
And she's also heard asking her friend,
the talent manager, Jerry
Schilling, for support
during this interview with Billy Bush.
Well, tonight
will be a wonderful night for Elvis.
Yes, I hope so.
And have you gotten to know Austin Butler
a little bit?
Yeah, I'm going to grab now.
Yes, a lot.
A lot, actually.
At this hour, it is still not clear
what caused her death.
Her mother,
Priscilla Presley,
saying in a statement
that her daughter
had been receiving medical attention
but did not share anything more
about how this could have happened.
Kyung Lah is OUTFRONT
And one 25 squad.
68 full of
paramedics responded to an emergency call
for help.
Hours later, Priscilla Presley,
mother of Lisa
Marie Presley, said
her daughter was rushed to the hospital
and then shared with fans
that the daughter of Elvis
had died at age 54.
I just I
I got chills
because that's how her father passed.
The child of the king of rock and Roll,
who lost her father
when she was nine,
had apparently succumbed
to cardiac arrest.
There are
about 350,000
cardiac arrests
every year in the United States.
So that's about one
almost every minute in this country.
So it's a very common occurrence.
And there are a lot of things
that can cause a cardiac arrest
without an autopsy, says cardiologist Dr.
Jonathan Reiner.
It's impossible to know why
a 54 year old
woman would suddenly suffer
from cardiac arrest
just two days before
mother and daughter
had attended the Golden Globes,
where a biopic on Elvis was honored.
I read that
Presley leaned on a friend
during this interview,
and just days before the awards show,
she spoke at Graceland of withdrawing
from public view
at a celebration of
what would have been her famous father's
80th birthday.
I keep saying
you're the only people that can bring
me out of my house.
Presley had
previously lived a very public life.
Marrying the King of Pop
before she would embark
on a singing career of her own
while she left the limelight.
In recent years,
she shared her personal struggles.
Presley wrote
about her addiction to opioids
saying In the foreword of this book,
You may read this and wonder how
after losing people close to me,
I also fell prey to opioids after
losing one of her
four children
to suicide over two years ago.
She wrote, You do not get over it.
You do not move on.
Period.
Dr.
Reiner says that in the wake of Presley's
cardiac arrest,
as well as a cardiac arrest of sports
writer Grant Wahl and NFL player
DeMar Hamlin,
there has been a scary
and unfortunate
rise of misinformation, Erin,
where conspiracy
theorists are trying to tie this
the vaccine safety Aaron.
Okay. Thank you very much. Kyung.
And joining me now is Kevin Frazier.
He's the co-host
of Entertainment Tonight.
He interviewed
Lisa Marie Presley
during her final public appearance
at the Golden Globe Awards on Tuesday.
And Kevin,
I appreciate your taking the time.
I'm sorry to be speaking to you
under these circumstances,
because you were there.
You were with Lisa Marie Presley
the last time she was seen alive.
In public.
We've got the
video of
you speaking with her
at the Golden Globes
for Entertainment Tonight.
I'll just play one of the exchanges
you had with her. Sure.
Hey, Lisa, how are you?
I know
this is a big night.
What was it
what was it like watching him on
you?
Good to see you.
Look so Hi, Lisa.
How you doing?
I hear a lot about you,
and I think you hear a lot about you.
Yes. Yes, absolutely.
What was it like watching
Austin on stage?
And during this movie
and the making of this movie?
It was mind blowing.
Truly mind blowing.
I really didn't know
what to do with myself after
after I saw it.
Yeah, I had to take like five days to
process it
because it was so incredible
and so spot on and so authentic
that, yeah,
I, I can't even describe
what it meant
you know, watching that.
I don't know.
I was I'm watching it through the screen.
The video,
she did appear to be a little unsteady,
maybe her eyes
a little heavy
and she's speaking slowly,
maybe misses a couple of parts of words.
But this is like in retrospect, right?
Seeing this,
you know,
we see the video of her on TikTok
being helped down the stairs
What did you see?
You know,
you were there with her in person.
What was your impression at that moment?
Erin, it was immediately
clear that she wasn't 100%.
But, you know,
you never speculate
on what's going on with someone.
She was there
to celebrate her father's legacy
through Austin.
And this was a big night.
Austin winning
the Golden Globe was a big night.
So she would definitely have to be there,
want to be there.
She's been with him
through this entire journey of the movie.
Elvis and her
and her mother
seemed to be in such a celebratory mood
but you obviously could tell
she wasn't 100%. Right.
So you felt that there.
And look, you know so much about her.
She was the sole heir
to her father's estate
inheriting Graceland when she was 25.
And she was there on Sunday. Right.
So there was the Golden Globes.
And on Sunday
she was there giving a speech on
what would have been
Elvis's 80th birthday.
Here's a part of that
Thank you.
I love you.
It's been a while.
Missed I missed you.
But I love you.
And keep saying you're the only people
that you're bringing me out of my house.
I'm not kidding
you.
You and I love you back,
and that's why I'm here.
So today
you would have been 88 years old,
and it's hard to believe
and just say what she said there.
You're the only people
who can bring me out of my house.
And I'm not kidding.
Of course,
sort of look at that differently now.
I think the point
there is that, you know,
she was still grieving
the death of her son, Benjamin,
and she has been very open and honest
about that.
She penned that
article in People about his death.
You've never really anyone
ever gets over the death of a child.
And you also have to remember that
since she has been small,
she has been the focus
of everyone's attention
as the sole heir, the
sole child of Elvis Presley.
They got divorced.
Priscilla and Elvis got divorced
when she was four years old.
So she
and then she left Graceland
and went to California,
and then
he passed away when she was nine.
So since that, she's carried that burden.
And, you know, this legacy
meant everything to her and her mother.
And having been there
several times
and watched her record music
and listen to her grow,
it was never an easy path for Lisa Marie.
She was always trying
to figure out her place in this world.
But I will tell you that
she loved her children
and her relationship with her mother was
so close and so special.